I think there's something special about
the fact that you were a newspaper
journalist that kind of training I
really respect and I was only after 10
years in the business remember how it I
became a columnist in 2003 back then
there was no social media and so before
then if you remember you could write
features you could be an investigative
reporter you could be a beat writer only
columnist had the license to express
their opinion and I wasn't allowed to do
that until 2003. didn't you want to say
to your boss I'd be a great columnist
stop putting me on the beat I had to
work my way up when I became a columnist
in 2003 I was the 21st African-American
21st black man in this nation's history
to become a general Sports columnist
there was only 20 black men before me 20
black people before me that pulled it
off so it was an incredible incredible
accomplishment which is why when you got
these bloggers out here talking this
[ __ ] sometimes and all of this other
stuff I remind folks excuse me I know
damn blogger I worked my way up to get
to this point I said I was I was living
off a tuna fishing Kool-Aid working in
Archdale North Carolina I did four
internships before I became a high
school reporter I worked for 14 months
at the New York daily news before I
covered College I got promoted seven
times at the Philadelphia Enquirer
before I became a columnist and all of
this was before ESPN ever came about my
opinion is earned it wasn't given to me
yes you see I agree with that I think
there's a reason a deeper reason why you
are the number one guy you have that
formal training that you had to sit
there and write articles without opinion
my credentials and and I'm particular
about this not with white folks you know
white folks that say screaming a and all
this that's cool man it's no big deal my
man Mad Dog Russo my buddy they don't
call him screaming they call them mad
dog but it works fine so be it but when
black folks don't embrace
what folks are trying to do and fend
that off that upsets me because I am
somebody that's trying to set a path for
future folks on the come up from my
community to be in this position one day
you don't allow someone to forget my
resume you if you're a black person all
of these jobs that I had all of this
work I put in all of these sacrifices I
made you're going to let somebody come
to me and say oh he just screams without
while forgetting all the stories that I
broke the dominance that I exhibited
covering the NBA and the way I built my
career over a span of 25 plus years
you're just gonna let them forget that
if they forget my resume what are they
going to do to your resume doesn't it
drive you nuts when someone says oh
Stephen A Smith bro he's just a rich
[ __ ] he doesn't know what it's like
in the hood he doesn't know this [ __ ]
and my exact words is
[ __ ] you you don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about you're clueless
look at my resume Google me as Shaq
would say Google me it's all there there
is nobody that can question my resume
because I've been I've done what all of
these reporters are doing and a matter
of fact I did it when it was harder now
to Howard do you realize what you could
do now what you literally could do now
you can sit back and wait for players to
tweet
right and just take a quote off of
social media and write a damn article
you don't have to break stories I had to
break stories
foreign